[Music]
hello and welcome to quad riga this week
germans witnessed street clashes that
reminded some of the mob violence that
paved the way for the nazis 90 years ago
right-wing demonstrators rampage through
the streets of the eastern city of
Chemnitz on sunday cutting down people
they believed to be immigrants thousands
assembled once again on monday and
clashed with counter protesters local
police and political leaders were
clearly overwhelmed critics called their
reaction too little and too late the
mass violence was triggered by the
murder early Sunday morning of a German
allegedly at the hands of two
middle-eastern asylum seekers right-wing
protests in Chemnitz what is the root of
this hate that is our topic today on
quadriga it's a pleasure to introduce
our guests and we welcome Karen Taylor
she's an expert on racism she's a member
of the SPD and heads its Committee on
migration and diversity and she says as
long as Germany does not deal with its
racism problem more people will be
hunted down because of their race and
not only in canvas and it's great to
have my colleague Hansa Pfeiffer on the
show he works for DW as an expert on
right-wing extremism and he says Germany
is facing a constitutional crisis
politicians and citizens increasingly
ignore the basic principles of Germany's
core values and finally we're pleased to
welcome back to the program mountain
layman he's a commentator for the daily
newspaper dear Tagish beagle and he says
the events in Chemnitz are shocking and
disgusting but by and large and
especially in a European perspective
Germany coped with the refugee crisis
quite well more than 300 thousand
migrants have found a job unemployment
is low the welfare system is strong so
welcome to all of you and Hans if you
would I'd like to start with what
happened as far as we know the facts how
did we go from a nighttime stabbing to
this kind of an escalation to mass
violence and posses hunting down
immigrants in the streets well
be as soon as the the news was spreaded
that somebody was killed and that that
through social media people get the
information that it probably could have
been to refugees committing the crime
which is now under under proof of the
authorities as soon as this happened
there had been insecurity and the
population and their spread the
discussion about about violence about
refugees as soon as they started and as
this as soon as this happened the the
the mobilization started through like
through citizens of the city but
especially through a right-wing groups
right-wing organizations and they spread
the news precisely to their affiliated
groups of also in other parts of Germany
trying to mobilize well it's a mixture
of a mop of the far-right and
demonstrators to protest in this city
and what then was taking place that a
mixture of emotions in this city because
of the crime together with well
organized neo-nazis from all over
Germany we're kind of taking over the
city and so what happened was not
spontaneous what was taking place in the
city it was this well-organized scheme
we have observed in many other conflicts
in cities wherever is something terrible
happened which was which was used by
organized neo-nazi groups for their
propaganda not given the role of social
media in escalating this and in steering
it would you say actually this is
something that could have taken place
anywhere it just happened to be chemnitz
because that's where the stabbing
occurred I would say these are two
different questions is it something that
is typical for the eastern part in
Germany or what the role of the social
media is I think social media fuels
things very fast because social media
instantaneously gives informations even
wrong information it was even said in
the beginning the man who was murdered
wanted to help a German girl from
the immigrants and so on all these
things which which it was actually false
and the police has no proof of that but
but these Kings if these things are
spreaded through the social media things
are happening very very fast and I would
say the the demonstrations on Sunday
we're indeed more spontaneously than
planned on Monday on Monday it was a
totally different affair and I agreed
completely that was not spontaneously
this was organized it happened in the
east because the East is a special place
for these things I would say that that
entire immigrant sentiments and the in
the East are in part like in the West or
in all over Europe the stateless control
of the borders crime is high
unemployment goes up the welfare state
is is ruined or something like this but
there's a special Eastern component to
this this is say this has to do with GDR
history with the civil war rhetoric
they're using we are the people the same
rhetoric they used when they brought
down the communist regime so I think the
anti-communism 30 years ago transformed
into anti-establishment anti-immigrant
movement right now can same question to
you
essentially the local authorities did
say that neo-nazis right-wing groups
poured in from all over Germany your
initial statement talked about racism in
places far beyond
chemnitz would you say that in fact this
could have taken place elsewhere as well
or do you see a unique local element in
this very virulent violence I think this
could have happened anywhere but the the
amount of violence which we see in
Chemnitz in which we especially see in
Saxony is kind of M characteristic for
this state because we have authorities
we have local politicians who deny the
existence of neo-nazi groups the
existence of the high amount of racism
within the state we have some statement
from the president of the state who is
in completely deny so I believe that
it's a linked to this lack of yeah
realization what is happening in his own
in his own State on the other side I
would also say that we have a main
problem in Germany as such to talk about
racism to talk about institutional
racism to talk about all the racism and
as long as we close our eyes for this
reality and I think this will happen or
can happen anywhere I want to come back
to the political response and to
politics a bit later but for now let us
start by hearing some voices from
Chemnitz itself how did the citizens see
these events and the role of their City
I am disappointed in eminence of course
it's all sad reactions were just to
right-wing chemnitz has changed for the
worse I don't want anyone to think I am
even if I'm standing here there's
trouble here every evening IRB's
confront each other I don't want to say
that with only foreigners you can't go
into the city any more without worrying
about something happening to you I'm sad
that this is happening here it's getting
out of hand
you feel unsafe going to the city as an
ordinary citizen if that's okay
hence to what degree is right-wing
xenophobia beginning to penetrate the
mainstream becoming acceptable even to
people to citizens who might think of
themselves as absolutely
middle-of-the-road
I think it's really popular right at the
moment but I'm not really surprised of
what's going on because I think it was
never absent these racist sentiments in
the society have never been away and we
we faced like groans like this in the
90s in Germany we had major attacks by
right-wing terrorist groups which were
supported also by part of the mainstream
even in the in the 80s and 70s we were
facing a long tradition of of of a lack
of empathy with the victims of these
right of this far-right so this is why I
would think it's not surprising that
they are that strong but what I would
think that right at the moment what
makes the situation quite even dangerous
for the society is that there there is
kind of a mix of a combination of those
who are like activist right-wing
activists with citizens and that they're
that they're quite a lot of normal
citizens normal like they're not
organized they are like from the
neighborhood and they don't feel any
trouble to to march against refugees
against the government side by side with
people is saluting Hitler and this is I
think it's not new but it's it's
becoming more and more dangerous current
survey showed service taken this week
after the events in candidates showed
that a majority of Germans condemned the
violence condemned what happened there
but not a majority of people who support
the right-wing AFD party which is very
strong in this particular region of
Germany would you say that the AFD which
is now present in the Bundestag is it
essentially normalizing these right-wing
xenophobic views definitely definitely
and we've seen it if in Chemnitz it was
the FD who actually
called for the first gathering on Sunday
to mourn the the person who died not
only to mourn this person but also to
show show the the amount of rage and
anger towards immigrants or so-called
immigrants so we've seen it in Chemnitz
but we also see it in the Bundestag as
such the language has changed we also
see it with the other parties we saw it
during the election campaign last year
in Germany that not only the Rd is on
the complete right but also with the
other parties we have to name the CDU we
also have to name the SPD when it comes
to rid rhetorics so I think it's very
dangerous that the FD has said yeah a
level standard which is low and not
protecting m migrants or minorities in
Germany I think I want to say one thing
because I think it's very important that
this movement is not only anti-migrant
it's it's a it's a major part of their
their their beliefs but it's far more
than just anti-migrant because they are
opposing a liberal society where people
we are talking about they are not
migrants they are just people of
different color of maybe it's the
gran-gran fairer and parents that
migrated to germany so they are not
migrants anymore only by law or by
whatever statistic and this is what
makes it so dangerous they are opposing
part of the German citizens just because
they have a different belief they have a
different religion and what this makes
we're going to hear exactly that a bit
later on come back to those particular
voices we heard two people saying they
don't feel secure on the streets of
their City do you have some sympathy for
that sense of insecurity that was
expressed there it was very clear that
the police intendant's were absolutely
overwhelmed by what happened and
completely inadequately prepared the
police and Sunday evening were 591
police officers confronting 6000
right-wing demonstrators and protesters
and and left winners as well who
protesters anti-fascists against them so
they were really under estimating the
level of organizing that was it would be
shown by /
the right-wing or anti immigrants on the
street so I think there was a failure of
State a failure of having a clear
picture what happened in their own town
this is one thing the other thing is no
I don't have sympathy for them there is
something that I mean if if in a couple
of months more than 1 million refugees
are pouring into a country then I think
a certain kind of level being concerned
about the the the the impacts is quite
normal we see it in every European state
Saxony borders Poland Hungary both are
governed by by right-wing populist
parties and and if you add the Italy and
Austria and Scandinavian countries and
the the the success of lepen and France
and so on and so on there is a kind of
non German aspects to it there's a
European aspect to this I would say
these are normal but the facts don't
come close crime rate is at its lowest
level since unification in Germany the
the surplus and the budget is going up
and up unemployment hasn't risen it has
decreased since the influx of Germans so
all these things have to be communicated
to the public and I think that's the
lack of the the government they don't do
it as strongly as they could Hans a lot
of people have been saying in the wake
of the cabinet's events that that
surplus in the budget should be
dedicated much more to supporting the
security services we have seen
persistent cuts in police budgets all
over Germany in recent years would you
say looking at what happened in Chemnitz
that the feelings of the police were
material in the sense of being
understaffed tactical or political I
think well they are understaffed I think
I would not like to be a policeman and
sexily because they all have in all the
different states and Germany they have
problems with being quite badly stuff
but I think it's it's a political
problem at its core we didn't and that's
because we've seen so many places where
quite similar situations
were started to grow or to come up but
police managed pretty well to to control
the situation
because they had a better they had a
better reaction or we're a political
reaction because they said we have to do
everything we can to get the situation
under control and if and that's what
Polly is read in the social media as
well as donors because we are all
sitting in our office reading social
media like oh my god look at all these
right-wing groups they are mobilizing
all over Germany this will be really
tough let's send our reporters to
Chemnitz because it will be a day of
violence and so it's it's hard to
believe that the police was not
following these all these accounts so I
would say it's a it's a wrong political
decision because they are not aware and
they don't have the empathy that's but I
would think they they have a lack of
empathy with the Troubles neo-nazis
could make because mostly they are not
they are not the target of them and they
might be understaffed but they always
could have asked the federal police for
help exactly in fact we do have some
indications that the police and other
officials at least in Saxony may
themselves be susceptible to right-wing
extremist views a case in Dresden has
been making headlines in August at a
demonstration by the anti immigrant
group pegida protesting Chancellor
Angela Merkel's refugee policy a
demonstrator asked police to prevent a
television crew from filming from
filming him the police honored his
demand and then it emerged that that
demonstrator was a member of the Saxony
State Criminal Police who just happened
to be taking part in the protest in his
free time Karen Taylor would you say
there is a major problem with too much
proximity between some members of the
police at least in this eastern region
of Germany and right-wing groups
themselves definitely we've seen it with
the NSU terror cell the group which
wasn't discovered by the state police
but rather discovered itself we've seen
it with this example just shown here
and I would say if we talk about
security we often also have to talk
about the security of people were not
white in this country because if there's
a lack of security right now there's
definitely a lack of security in
candidates for me there's so-called
no-go areas everywhere in this country
even in Berlin the capital of Germany so
I believe if we talked about lack of
empathy I would say it's a lack of
protecting basic human rights for people
who are living in this country so that
is one of the major main major issues
here but then again in Chemnitz and also
Saxony itself we've already talked about
that this development from coming from a
rapid GDR which was kind of enclosed if
we also look about at the numbers
they're not so many migrants there are
not so many people of color this is the
region where we have the fewest exactly
or in residents procuct suddenly that
seems like an enormous paradox can you
explain that very well-researched yes
it's a basic seven percent in Chemnitz
well well there's migration at its low
then those you know phobic or racist
thoughts are at a high you can maybe
explain it with Martin Luther King was
said if there's no contact there's fear
and so I guess it's also and then again
this being part of a political party I
say the politicians have a great
responsibility here we live in a
globalized economy globalized world of
course migration and diversity is its
everyday life so to portray that Germany
is a white and coast enclosed country
it's just wrong so we need to change
this this rhetoric about us being
protected by everything which happens
around us and rather be be honest to
ourself and say yeah migration is a
reality and we'll have people coming in
and out of the country
I would like briefly to add two points
for it might be special in Saxony and
the east of Germany first of all with
the
40 years of GDR government rules there
how was National Socialism taught in
schools as a Western affair has nothing
to do with GDR history nothing to do
with the eastern history the Nazis were
part of the Western society not of the
East so this I think caused a tremendous
lack of understanding for the roots of
racism and National Socialism of these
things the second point is solidarity
when the influx of refugees were in the
fall of 2015
basically the German government asked
all the Germans for for help and for
support and shows solidarity with these
people showing solidarity from bottom up
was part of the GDR rhetoric solidarity
with other communist Russians Cubans and
so on and so on so they got is sort of
they are anti solidarity feelings
because they were forced to show
solidarity in the first place did 30
years ago
perhaps the one of the paradoxical
aspects is to see in a region that had
been communist a swing to a kind of
German nationalist thinking that many
people assumed was long over let's take
a look at one more incident that
occurred in the region of Saxony last
weekend the right-wing identitarian
movement held a festival in Dresden our
colleague you Jafar abdul karim was
there
he spoke with activists and other
visitors at the event and ultimately
became a target of racism himself that's
I want Germany to stay Germany lunch
blight what does that mean it means what
I said if you don't understand that
that's your problem then you've got a
big problem I'm an immigrant
yeah good case and you're just a German
citizen not a German or part of German
society or the German people it just
woke some Dutchman from my point of view
you don't belong to the German people
keep the camera on I know how this works
does it work explain what you need and
broadcast it you know what if you don't
like it here then go somewhere you like
better
Sahin was it was invisible go back where
you came from and it's interesting to
hear one of the speakers in that
incident deprecating german citizenship
essentially saying you're only a german
citizen it is troublingly reminiscent
for many of us of that old blood and
soil idea of what it means to be a
German this is why I think that we have
a constitutional crisis because these
voices they have a strong voice now in
the parliaments of Germany with the
far-right AFD and they becoming more and
more popular and they could even win
elections in some regions in Germany and
because they started to bring up this
this topic that like like blaming
Germans as not German just because of
their skin colour just because of their
name just because they have dark hair or
whatever just because of their religion
that they start to to disfavor them to
other Germans and that they that they
separate and I think this is really
dangerous if those people who have
started this will get the power and will
do the laws then then we will see a
different Germany than we have nowadays
okay this week the UN Commissioner for
Human Rights expressed his enormous
dismay over what was happening in
Chemnitz and said he wants to see a much
stronger response and real action from
politicians all over Europe but also in
Germany now we have heard some strong
words from German leaders this week but
what specifically do they need to do
more and I'm asking you also as a member
of the Social Democratic Party which is
one of the parties that is governing in
Saxony what would you want to see your
party doing that it's not doing now
there are several things I would like a
party to do and for one I'd like to talk
about representation if you look at the
SPD and different political parties in
Germany they don't really represent the
people in Germany because if we look at
them it's it's mostly white and mostly
met male so we need to foster a need to
start
with talking to the people who belonged
to this country as well and in order to
foster them and push them into political
responsibility this is one major major
issue we have with all the political
parties including the SPD another thing
is we need to talk about racism not only
in the connection of neo-nazis and
right-wing extremism but really talk
about the issue as such see racism as a
structural problem as a problem of
privileges for one part of the country
and disadvantages for the other country
and for the other part so we really need
to talk about what it means to actually
tackle racism and not only right-wing
extremism that's another part and the
third thing I would suggest is to really
look at these yeah look at these cells
really look at these areas in Germany
which are traveled we don't want to put
all of them is the eastern Germany into
one pot but it's not a coincidence that
is this has been happening again and
again in Saxony so we really need to
look at these different cells one word
do you fault the SPD leaders in Sauk
City for not taking a stronger stand I
mean we CTD or leadership in Saxony so
for that yes I do blame the city
leadership definitely thank you very
much Martin lemming pants two sentences
what do you politicians need to do that
they're not doing now is strong we have
to to point out who the successes of
integrating many many refugees in work
in labor in in languages and things like
that and then they don't have to give
them the the chance to show themselves
to be Pro German they are anti German as
well and politics have to strengthen and
support those in those small little
rural parts of Germany we're opposing
this violence we're opposing the
far-right and who are opposing racism
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us and thanks to you out
there for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
you